we might not know what a
four-dimensional sphere looks like but
we can describe it mathematically on a
two-dimensional coordinate grid with an
X and A y-axis we can describe a circle
with a radius one using the equation x
squared plus y squared is equal to one
using a three-dimensional coordinate
system with X Y and Z axes we can
describe a sphere with a radius one
using the equation x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared is equal to one a
four-dimensional hypersphere could be
described by adding one more Dimension
we could call it w w for Wombo then the
equation of our hypersphere would be x
squared plus y squared plus Z squared
plus W Squared is equal to one it's
amazing to me that math within our grasp
can be used to describe shapes beyond
our imagination